France once revolutionary now a catalyst
for furious populist movements a country
where protest is in the blood and over
the last year a Nation defenseless
against the yellow vests Paris landmarks
of triumph left effaced and its iconic
street smashed and looters it even left
the most jaded well shocked
[Applause]
[Music]
you
machan had come to power with his own
idea of a French Revolution it was one
of reform he vowed not to fall on his
sword as others before him by not giving
in to protest movements but even he was
forced into a treat
the planned carbon tax hike was
abandoned
he opened the state purse to boost
low-income households makan even said he
was their kindred spirit if being a
yellow vest means been in favor of
higher salaries and the more effective
Parliament then I am a yellow vest but
for many yellow vests those promises
were empty at first macron didn't give
way they were in the promises and donkey
backtracked there was a text bonus but
not every company had the resources to
offer it he also promised 100 euros
extra for people a minimum wage but in
the end we realized it was only for
those and social security the anger
continued to spill out onto the streets
while some yellow vests were caught up
in the violence for the most part
protesters argue their movement had been
infiltrated by extremists
it's the radicals who go out for
violence it's an adrenaline kick for
them it makes them feel good I suppose
but there are also people who become
violent because they are being attacked
by tear gas and police battens
they've tried to discredit the movement
by showing images of burning trash cans
and cars and also to make sure that the
rest of the population don't join the
movement
the police don't understand anything the
government owes them money but instead
of marching with us they heed the
protesters
the violence made a big impression on me
the police against our guys I have been
to every protest in Paris and I saw
things I should never have seen people
were hit in the back for the forces of
peace and order they too have been left
scarred by the violence there was a
police car
we had been besieged by protesters and
they tried to put fire inside it the the
French policeman we are very very close
to use their weapons to get out there
was also the Arc de Triomphe
there was a charge of police officers so
they were hype they were exhausted and
they were there was a come to attack
from there many as a protester and we
almost lost one man there and according
to this police union the problems were
compounded from the very top it was a
mess it was a mess and we had bad Intel
we had bad leadership there was no in
fact bad leadership in Preiser meanwhile
for Letitia de ville the struggle
continues but she's also aware the
weekly protests may have lost some of
their initial impact so how will the
yellow vests movement adapt in the
future to change the system she says you
need to be inside it I decided to join
the local team because if we can't find
the problem from the outside we should
do it from the inside I also invited the
other yellow vest activists with similar
views to do the same if they become a
counselor or a deputy they will be
inside the system and we will be able to
change it whatever your view on the
jealousy on the yellow vest movement one
thing is indisputable they've had a
profound effect on France over the last
year now could be a pivotal moment to
see if they will continue to burn a
torch under the current administration
this weekend we may find out charlotte
even ski
Artie Paris
you